feminist women out there are not going
to like this women are perishing in this
modern world more than men well that's
terrifying if we want to exist on this
planet we're going to have to Dr Mindy
Peltz renowned functional health expert
bestselling also and keynote speaker one
of the leading voices from educating us
about our bodies spending two decades
helping Millions worldwide you got
pretty famous from talking about this
certain subject matter which is fasting
what do I need to know research shows
it's going to make me stronger more lean
1300 percent increase in testosterone in
men oh wow we see inflammation go down
growth hormone go UPS the hormone that
keeps you young and helps you burn fat
you know where it dropped the most
amount of weight belly yep literally
takes cells that are turning into cancer
and it gets rid of those you are tapping
into a healing state that you never knew
was there I'm sold where do I start so
the first place to start is menstruation
or the Big M is considered a taboo topic
I'm gonna say something which is really
embarrassing here I know nothing about
menstrual cycles I'm in a relationship
what advice have you got for me well the
first is do you know her cycle
moving on tell me about your childhood
let me give you gold the first two days
give her some space if you have any
conflict you want to resolve with her do
it between day two and day 12. her
libido is going to be the highest
between day 10 and day 15. and then
here's the goal you're gonna have to
report back to me how this works around
day 17. this is where you got it
once in a while on this podcast I have a
conversation that I desperately wish I'd
had sooner this is one of those
conversations I'd heard about fasting
but I had no idea no idea at all of its
potentially life-changing impact weight
loss your sex life A woman's menstrual
cycle how to heal from illness and
injury the incredible power of fasting
I'm incredibly happy that you chose to
listen to this particular conversation
because if you're like me and you've
never really taken the time to
understand fasting and you don't
understand the six types of fasting then
maybe this is the conversation you've
always needed to hear because it
certainly was for me you are really
really going to enjoy this one take my
word for it
[Music]
Mindy
if you took the full body of work that
you've produced over the last let's say
10 years and the work that you're going
to produce over the next 10 years and
you had to summarize
the mission that you're on and why it
matters
how would you do that well that's a
great question
um I'm trying to empower people to
believe in themselves again and I want
to do that through everything that in
our lifestyle that Taps into our body's
own ability to heal itself we've gotten
so far off course we don't even realize
that we're giving so much of our health
power away our happiness power away and
all we've got to do is come back home to
ourselves and learn that every single
thing inside of us every cell every
neuron everything is working for us not
against us and we have to stop
villainizing our body we got to figure
out how to believe in ourselves again
we're the ones that are going to save
ourselves and we've just lost our way
what have we fallen into the Trap of
believing
well in the health World we've totally
fallen into the Trap that if I take this
pill if I do this diet if I do this
exercise then that will cure me
nobody cures you you cure yourself and
so you have to start to look at the
human body as this self-healing organism
that's always figuring out how to keep
you alive how to keep you at your best
and if you're not feeling at your best
then the only thing you to look at is
that there's an interference there's a
physical emotional spiritual chemical
interference that is pulling you away
from this power that's inside of you so
that you can start to heal Once you pull
those away you see yourself in a whole
new light I mean this is what fasting
did for millions of people you just see
yourself so differently in what you're
capable of doing
where have we gone wrong in terms of our
attitude towards what it is to be a
human because you know I often think
much of the
Health advice that what is thrown at us
these days
has this underlying belief that like in
some way we're broken yeah
yeah oh my I I so agree with you it's
the messaging
is like you did you did something wrong
song you have a genetic profile that
you're doomed to have a you know a
disastrous outcome and everything is is
is exogenously blamed at us and I really
think that that comes from not only our
Health Care system and I and I'm not
trying to bash the Health Care System
but we have lost our way and it comes
from for women specifically it comes
from the messaging we get from you know
social media and magazines like
everything is outside in we got to go
inside out now and start asking what we
want on a physical spiritual emotional
level so that we can create the life we
want and stop looking outside for the
answers we got to go within I love that
inside inside out inside out inside out
living
you go pretty famous from talking about
this certain subject matter which is
fasting yeah now I want to talk about
fasting because I've heard about it and
I I'm sure here I represent a lot of my
audience right now I've heard the term
fasting I've heard loads of people in
recent times over the last I'd say two
years get really excited about it and
say that it's a good thing yeah but
that's really the extent of my knowledge
on the subject so let's just start right
there you mean you wrote a book called
fast like a girl you've got so much
content out on the internet about
fasting for both men and women
this book was written in 2022
why why why are you so focused on
fasting why do I need to care about it
What's it gonna do for me it's the
quickest antidote to what we just said
if we've got all this physical emotional
chemical stress coming at us we've got
taste buds we've got to change we've got
behaviors we have to change there's a
lot there
but I can show you how to compress your
eating window into a 10 hour eating
window leaving 14 hours for fasting
something as simple as 14 hours and I
can show you how you can start to heal
yourself without money without time
it's you are literally tapping into a
healing state that you never knew was
there and I think part of why we've had
so many people pour on to YouTube and so
many women gravitate to the book is that
it's it's so once you learn how to fast
you start to see your body in this whole
new way it can absolutely heal itself so
for me fasting became this incredible
tool that everybody could do
and we just had to learn how to do it
the women that I'm watching that are
just dropping I mean men and women
hundreds of pounds and medications
they're getting off of and mental health
that's coming back just because I taught
them how to compress their eating window
and leave a longer time for rest so
their body can repair that is all each
individual is doing that I didn't do
that I'm the type of person that very
much needs like
stats I believe things I'm one of those
people and once I've got the stats or
some kind of like scientific evidence
then I'm all in beautiful what do I need
to know
from a scientific standpoint what
research has been done on fasting okay
so let's let's go through the basic
principle of fasting and I think this
will help everybody is that you have two
metabolisms so you burn energy when you
eat
and you burn energy when you don't eat
but there are two different mechanisms
so when you eat like let's use myself as
an example I had eggs and some avocado
for like around 11 o'clock today so
that's going to bring my blood sugar up
now as my blood sugar starts to drop
what's gonna happen is my body's gonna
switch over into this other Energy
System
and I call this the fat burning Energy
System I call this one the sugar burner
Energy System when it switches over into
this fat burning Energy System it starts
to make a byproduct called a ketone
and that Ketone will go up into the
brain and it starts to repair your brain
and what most people don't realize is
your brain is needs 50 ketones 50
glucose so you're giving a fuel source
to your brain that it desperately needs
which is why people when they fast are
like their mental Clarity goes up their
cognition improves their brain fog goes
away because you're literally giving a
fuel source to your brain that it may
never had have been given before
it takes about eight somewhere between
eight hours to metabolically switch over
into this fat burning Place ah okay so
if I'm doing a podcast and I want to be
sharp yes I shouldn't eat eight hours
before yes ah
did you come back in seven hours seven
out yeah yeah
sure I should have given you the memo
before we got here yeah so I think of it
like a hybrid car you know you you're
you switch over into this fat burning
place so at eight hours you start to
make the switch by about 12 hours your
body's now starting to make a good dose
of ketones the brain is excited so
you're getting that mental Clarity
ketones turn off the hunger hormone so
you also when you switch over there's
going to be a point which you're not
hungry and that all happens in about 12
hours but you're also if you stay there
a little longer if you stay there and
you go 14 hours 15 hours so check this
out research shows at 15 hours we see
growth hormone go up okay growth hormone
is the hormone that keeps you young and
helps you burn fat we also see in men
thirteen hundred percent increase in
testosterone just from somewhere between
a 13 to 15 hour or fast
13 percent increase in natural
testosterone stores and we can explain
why that happens in a moment and then we
start to see inflammation go down so all
of a sudden if you have people who have
like joints that are hurting they start
doing 15 hours of fasting every day and
they're like God you know my joints just
don't have that same stiffness in them
anymore
but if you stay in that fasted window
you keep going 17 hours your brilliant
body turns within and it goes wait a
second no food's coming in we better get
stronger so it literally takes this the
bad cells the cells that are slowing you
down the cells that are turning into
cancer and it gets rid of those they're
called senescent cells and it literally
recycles them out of your system and it
goes into the cells that are still
usable and it makes them stronger it
fixes the intercellular parts we call
that autophagy and that actually was the
if you want stats the Nobel Prize in
2015 by a Japanese scientist Dr osumi he
won the Nobel Prize in medicine and
Physiology for this term called
autophagy and that's when you go without
food your cell your cells will heal
themselves
that was back in 2015.
so I want to go into all of that I want
to start with why why does why does
fasting help so much and really like
what I'm getting at there is if this
if the effects of this are so profound
in so many ways then where did we go
wrong because from what I you know have
been told breakfast lunch dinner yeah
breakfast lunch dinner and then maybe
you know dessert yeah and then you know
yeah that's the narrative that I was
brought up on yeah well breakfast is the
most important meal of the day I've done
a lot of research on that phrase do you
know where it came from no it was
actually and I don't mean to diss any
companies out there but it was a tagline
that they came up with for corn flakes
for Kellogg's Corn Flakes back in the
1970s they needed a tagline that made
people eat corn flakes in the morning
and so they came up with corn flakes
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day
and that has continued until this day we
I can't find any research and and many
other fasting experts many other blood
sugar experts will tell you the same
thing there's just no research showing
that breakfast is the most important
meal of the day so that became that
became a a myth that we need to bust
second myth we've been taught is you can
speed your metabolism up the more you
eat six meals a day remember that one
okay also a myth there is no evidence
that the more you eat the faster your
metabolism will be the fat if you want a
faster metabolism you need to know how
to metabolically switch you need to know
how to go from sugar burner to fat
burner and that's where you start to
lose weight so that's the second the
other myth that I feel like we have to
break apart and then we have this you
know I can tell you as a mother and I
and this is you know not for anybody to
have mommy guilt but what we do as
parents is we have certain statements we
make to our kids like you know breakfast
dinner's being served the kitchen's
closing in an hour
um you need to eat lunch you need to eat
breakfast like we are programmed when to
eat by a clock not by our own internal
sense so kids are raised to eat
according to a clock not according to
when they want to eat
um
we don't say am I hungry right now
that's so true we will wait until 1 pm
to have lunch and the morning we wake up
we feel like we we have to have
breakfast we're doing something wrong
yep and then dinner time you know
anytime between I know six and eight
we have to sit down and eat again or
we're doing something wrong yep
like have you like if you just unwind
that yeah where did that come from right
from your parents and it came from a
schedule what did my ancestors do before
my parents existed and the schedules
existed I can tell you exactly what they
did what did they do they came out of
the cave I'm gonna go back to the our
Primal friends go back to Arcade friends
they came out of a cave they didn't have
refrigerator they didn't have a pantry
they didn't have doordash they had to go
find food did they have any baits they
didn't have ubereats yeah I'm pretty
sure they didn't have ubereats but what
they did is they came out of the cave
and they went to go hunt food
sometimes they could make a kill really
easily and bring it home and they would
feast
sometimes the kill wasn't as easy and
they had to go far to find an animal to
kill exercise
exercise but what did they do when they
had to go super far and they couldn't
get food they switched over into this
ketogenic Energy System and that
ketogenic Energy System supercharged
them because every cell in the human
body is the number one priority of our
cells is survival
so we were built to make sure we could
stay alive in the absence of food
so their ketones kicked in and when
ketones kicked in they became mentally
very focused so they could go find food
they were able to stay calm ketones will
affect a neurotransmitter called Gaba
and cause Gaba to come on so you feel
calm you're focused ketones will power
up your muscles so that all of a sudden
you have this incredible muscular energy
all because
they were meant to go find food so they
can bring it home okay so the body which
is orientated towards survival when you
hadn't eaten it invests a lot of its
sort of resources in your brain to
increase the chances that you'll catch
something to eat so that's why when I
fast or when I haven't eaten I'm very
focused I'm very articulate that's right
it seems um and I perform at my best
Bingo that's it makes sense and then
what what do they do when they got a
Kill
they came home and they feasted
they didn't necessarily ration it out
they ate and then they divided up again
amongst the tribe and then they went out
again until when the food was gone maybe
a couple days maybe they'd Feast for a
couple days when the food was gone they
go out again
it's called Feast famine cycling it is
how humans were meant to be to live the
challenge we have is we have access to
food all the time that we are you know
feasting has taken on a really negative
connotation because we're feasting on
the wrong fids but if we could go back
and just be like our Primal friends and
we could learn how to go in and out of
this Feast famine cycling using fasting
as as a tool for performance for healing
and using food in the proper way and
eating the right food so that our brains
will work well and you know there's a
whole hormonal pack or sense of of food
that can help support hormones if we're
really conscious about the quality of
the food that we eat we're now mimicking
what our Primal ancestors were doing
does that also imply that we should
exercise fasted because I was thinking
if thinking about my ancestors they
would have been doing the most physical
activity when they hadn't eaten yet
that's right yeah they would have been
doing the most physical activity right
before they ate yeah so really
interesting point and and you and I were
talking about this in the beginning is
that when you exercise in a fasted state
you're going to get rid of the glucose
that's been stored in your muscles
so as that glucose comes out because
your body needs it to go you know you're
you don't work a hundred percent off of
ketones and a hundred percent off of
glucose you're needing both of them at
both at different moments of your day so
when you're exercising in a fasted State
you're getting ketones and your muscles
are releasing stored sugar
which is great for anybody who wants to
lose weight because now you can lean out
those muscles now let's go back to what
our Primal ancestors did when they came
home they meet they ate protein and they
stimulated something called mtor mtor is
when you actually create muscle growth
and what we now know is it takes about
30 grams of protein to trigger these
amino acid receptor sites in the muscles
to cause them to grow stronger
so for you if you work out in a fasted
State you're going to release all those
stores you're going to have those
ketones for performance but then you
want to follow that up with protein so
you can build your muscles strong and
that is a hack that has worked
incredibly well for so many people okay
historically people have thought that
fasting
is a one-size kind of fits all
um technique and there's one kind of
fasting which is you just I don't know
you might just not eat for a prolonged
period of time but in your book and it
throughout your work you describe these
six different types of fasting yeah what
are the six types of fasting and tell me
what the the difference is and outcome
and benefit yeah it's a great question
so again fasting is when we switch over
so now we're in the fat burning uh place
at about 13 to 15 hours we start making
ketones this is intermittent fasting
that's pretty much what most people when
they say they're intermittent fasting
that's what they're doing okay they'll
take 12 to 16 hours yeah they're making
ketones or testosterones going up
inflammation is coming down hunger might
be going away they're kind of having
this they might be a lot of people lose
weight with that it's it's kind of the
most common fast does it matter from the
window doesn't matter what time I start
what time I am you get to choose you
choose what that window should be so I
could eat at 3am
you could there's a whole nother level
we can talk about why you don't want to
eat in the dark what's ideal an ideal
window
um I really like it depends on the on
the time of the year but in the summer I
really like somewhere if you're going to
do an eight hour eating window like 11
to 7 in the summer and then in the
winter because it's darker earlier you
would do more like a like a 10 to 5 kind
of eating window it's not so hard to do
eleven right
not hard at all not hard at all that's
not that's not fasting that's that's
just a slight having a slightly later
breakfast and a slightly earlier dinner
yeah but it's it's like being
intentional right yeah exactly because
you know what you gotta you gotta keep
blood sugar low otherwise the minute
blood sugar goes up you're gonna switch
over right so you can't put it you know
if you walk past the kitchen and put a
grape in your mouth
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah which is
you've pulled yourself yes yes so that's
the first type of the sixth fasting
um styles the second is I'm gonna try
and say this word or
ought off Audrey
autophagy it's one way of saying it
people say either call it
um autophagy or autophagy people say it
different
yeah I kind of landed on autophagy I
feel like autophagy is the best way to
say it what's on Fiji fasting what's
that so autophagy fasting is about 17
hours in without without food your cells
will turn within and they'll start to
heal themselves and that was what Dr
osumi's big uh Discovery was is that the
cells clean themselves up so what's
interesting on this one and this is
something I really want to get out to
the world is that when you stimulate
autophagy what you're doing is you're
turning on the intelligence inside the
cell and that intelligence is looking
around and it's going hey there's a
virus there's a bacteria get them out so
let's push these infections out of the
cell that mitochondria it's not working
well we need to repair it that
endoplasmic reticulum inside here it's
it's lagging we need to fix it so it
literally goes in and fixes everything
inside the cell just at 17 hours but one
of the greatest studies that was I've
seen in fasting was done during covid
and it showed that if a virus comes into
a cell that's in a state of autophagy it
can't replicate viruses have to live off
of your energy system so when viruses go
into a cell that's Laden with glucose
they have a party in there they love
that they munch on that and then they go
out and they start replicating if you
were in a fasted State when a virus
comes in it can't replicate there's
nothing inside that cell for that virus
to take over and it dies
why does that happen what's the reason
for the the that sort of the CEO Within
Myself looking around and saying right
let's clean all this stuff up well
because the it when once you've
stimulated autophagy there is one goal
for that cell and that is survival so
everything in there is on high alert
okay everything is going to be in your
survival interest so a virus is not in
your survival interest so it pushes it
out so it's kind of like an emergency
signal because there's not been food for
a while so yeah it's kind of like the
last
the last attempt to do everything the
body can to help you make it through
this period of hunger that's right
that's right you've put yourself in this
state of extreme healing and it's all
based off of this idea that your body
wants to stay alive
okay so that's are you writing a book
that that's good for balancing sex
hormones and preventing colds so yeah
with with autophagy it's great for
preventing colds here's what's
interesting about autophagy for sex
hormones is that the major part of your
brain for both men and women that
control hormonal all hormonal control is
your hypothalamus and pituitary
that part of the brain does not have a
blood-brain barrier so it's very
vulnerable to toxins
so whenever we have massive toxic
exposure that part of the brain starts
to malfunction we see this with
polycystic ovarian syndrome most common
hormonal imbalance for women well a lot
of that is this imbalance of
testosterone and estrogen and there's a
huge toxic piece that has destroyed or
or interfered with the part of the brain
that controls hormones
so when we look at autophagy there are
certain parts of our system that are
more uh easily influenced by autophagy
than others well it turns out the
hypothalamus and the pituitary are
easily influenced by autophagy and can
repair themselves when they're in the
state of autophagy
the other interesting cellular makeup
that is highly influenced by autophagy
are the cells around the testes and the
cells around the ovaries those are the
the cells that are putting out sex
hormones and if you that whole system is
malfunctioning when you go into a state
of autophagy those cells will respond
and become better cells and be better at
producing these hormones because of you
dipping in and out of the state of
autophagy
that really got me thinking because I've
been looking at a lot of companies from
an investment standpoint at the moment
that are trying to solve for this macro
decline in male testosterone you know I
was I had a few guests come on this
podcast and tell me that male
testosterone has been declined declining
year over year and then kind of paired
with that we're becoming more and more
sexless our libidos seem to be in
Decline I've got a lot of close friends
of mine that are taking certain hormonal
um supplements to try and get their
libidos back up and for the first time
ever in on a show called Dragon's Den
that I'm on in the UK we had someone
come into the den for an investment that
was producing a supplement to try and
get our sex drives back feels like a big
macro conversation that we're not having
and looking at your work and the work
around you've done about fasting and
what you said there it seems like there
could potentially be a link yeah between
the two the ways we're living our life
and what we're eating and our decline in
testosterone and our libidos there's a
beautiful book I don't know if you've
read it called countdown
and it's about the sperm counts going
down in across the world and I actually
brought her onto my podcast the woman
who wrote the book and she said that
there's one chemical that's reducing uh
sperm counts more than any and it's
phthalates
and phthalates are in fragrances
they're in our colognes they're in our
perfumes they're in our laundry
detergents they're in our air fresheners
they also are now infiltrated into our
water so they've infiltrated into
they're now being sprayed on our Foods
animals that are drinking the water have
phthalates in them so it's the number
one toxin that's destroying testosterone
levels and it's a brilliant book that
she wrote
you talk about in the reset factory your
first book from 2016 chapter 10. you
said something which I hadn't quite
um appreciated you said that even the
things we put on our skin are absorbed
into our body and then they go directly
into our bloodstream and into our
kidneys I didn't think when I read that
it got me thinking because there's so
many things that I sort of unconsciously
just spray on my body right every day
and I never look at what's in them
because I just think it's on the outside
and it'll wash off yep but now you're
saying that yeah your skin is a
breathable organ
so it's going to push toxins out and
it's going to take toxins in so think
about if you've ever like eaten
something that didn't react well with
you you might get a rash that's your
brilliant body trying to push that toxin
out but the same thing happens when you
put something on your skin it actually
goes into your body so a good general
rule is if you aren't willing to eat it
don't put it on your skin
and beyond that if we even look at at
the microbiome you have bacteria on your
skin that protect you and that bacteria
is are actually talking to the bacteria
in our gut there's actually a connection
between the two bacteria so if you start
putting things on your skin that destroy
that microbiome you're actually going to
ultimately have an adverse effect on the
microbiome in your gut so what you put
on your skin is massively important and
then the smell we know the hippocampus
which is the seat of Alzheimer's and
Dementia is also where the olfactory
nerve innervates so when we smell
something toxic and breathe something
toxic in it goes straight into the
hippocampus and starts to create
degeneration in those neurons that are
ultimately can lead to dementia and
Alzheimer's
toxicity is a huge human problem
toxicity
when you say the word toxicity how are
you defining that you're saying like
toxic chemicals that we introduced into
our lives on our skin consume inhale
have around us Bingo yeah and better in
our Foods Etc Bingo what is what are
some of the the most toxic chemicals or
Foods or products that we consume
without thinking that you think we need
to stop consuming
on a day-to-day basis oh here's the most
the easiest one is Plastics BPA plastic
they say that it's that there's it's not
a matter of if you have plastic in your
body it's a matter of how much
so let's use it in in context of
something that people are really
motivated by which is weight loss what's
BPA plastics it's it's a it's a chemical
within plastic that's within our water
bottles it's on in our Tupperware
um they actually are putting they're
saying that they're now in the
microfibers of our of our clothes and
that's being washed out too it gets
really depressing when you start talking
about toxins gets washed out into our
oceans so but for the sake of Simplicity
it's it's you know bottles mostly that
you see but you know we've got plastic
containers we've got plastic plates
we've got plastic everything and that is
has BPA in it and that is a a toxin that
destroys human health and the biggest
and most interesting thing that BPA
Plastics do is there was a study around
something called a negoody mouse
and they took this mouse that had a gene
for obesity and they were twins they fed
them the same food they gave them the
same amount of exercise but one of the
mice got introduced BPA plastic and the
one that got the BPA plastic all of a
sudden started to gain weight and the
hair color started to change
and they that was the only difference
between these two mouse mice with the
same genetic profile
and so now when they detox the BPA
plastic out the mouse lost weight
so that was the beginning of us
understanding a term called obesogens
and obesogens are toxins that actually
make us insulin resistant actually cause
us to hold on to more weight and that's
just one category of toxins
well that's terrifying
it is terrifying to be completely you
know from the center of my heart
this is it's this is why we have to
educate ourselves this is why we have to
wake up we have to understand
that we are living in the most toxic
time in human history and it doesn't
it's not just mental stress it's not
just social media it's a barrage of all
of that that is pulling us off course
and I can tell you that I have sat with
some of the most brilliant doctors who
are generally so concerned on the
direction of humanity and where we're
going because of the abundance of these
toxins
as you said that I could see a sadness
in your face
where does that come from
I think it's really easy when you hear a
Pog has like this and what I'm saying to
reject what I'm saying because it's it's
too overwhelming
to understand
what the evolutionary mismatch we're in
right now
we
so many people are suffering whether
it's physical or mental mentally and
they don't realize that it's everything
from the food to their shampoos to the
plastic water bottles it's it's so vast
and yet nobody's doing anything about
it and and that's where my heart hurts
it's like
people are suffering that don't need to
be suffering and if they understood that
the modern world we're living in has
taken us so off course with our health
and we've got to start to one by one
figure out how to bring it back on
course
and you know yesterday I sat with um Dr
Dale bredesen on my and interviewed him
on my podcast he wrote a book called the
end of Alzheimer's
and he laid out seven things that we
need to do to stop all Alzheimer's and
he strongly feels that Alzheimer's is
optional you don't have to you don't
have to get that
and those seven things
are so intense like it's everything from
detoxing to metabolically switching to
prioritizing sleep to human connection
to
um understanding you know what the best
exercise is for you
and it's easy for humans to look at
those seven things and go I'm out I
can't do all that
but we if we want to exist on this
planet we're going to have to do that
that's the new level of Health we're in
right now and I'm I love being the
cheerleader I want to be the one that's
like come on we can do it but I also
need people to understand that where
we're living as humans right now is a
very very dangerous place and it's just
in the existence of moving in and out of
grocery stores and restaurants and you
know and the drugstore everything has a
toxic insult on us
and it's overwhelming it's overwhelming
drastic action because we've we're so
drastically far away from where we're
supposed to be where our ancestors were
yeah we've built up this Society that's
full of plastics and toxins and alcohol
and drugs and sugar everywhere and I
can't move in bloody New York City which
is where we are now without someone
offering me
you know every block is almost every
block is
really bad food horrible but food that
tempts the certain part of my brain that
maybe is looking to help me stay alive
and to survive whether it's pizza or
sweets or whatever it might be yeah
um so it is difficult and I have a great
deal of empathy for anyone that's
struggling yeah with it me too
me too it's it's a it's it's it's it's
we've hit a point where the door out of
poor health is multifaceted
it's not just one door
and if you're healthy and you're just
like you know someone like you just
wants to get in better shape then the
path is a little bit easier
but what do we do for the for the person
that gets the cancer diagnosis what do
we do for the woman who's suicidal in
going through her menopause years like
where are we helping her how are we
getting to them
and each time they walk into their
doctor's office they're typically giving
getting a pill and not being taught how
to live a life that works with their
body in this modern world that's where
we have to get to
quick one before we get back to this
episode just give me 30 seconds of your
time
two things I wanted to say the first
thing is a huge thank you for listening
and tuning in to the show week after
week means the world to all of us and
this really is a dream that we
absolutely never had and couldn't have
imagined getting to this place
secondly it's a dream where we feel like
we're only just getting started and if
you enjoy what we do here please join
the 24 of people who watch this channel
regularly and have hit the Subscribe
button means more than I can say and if
you hit that subscribe button here's a
promise I'm going to make to you I'm
gonna do everything in my power to make
this show as good as I can now and into
the future we're going to deliver the
guests that you want me to speak to and
we're going to continue to keep doing
all of the things you love about the
show
thank you thank you so much back to the
episode you told me about the first two
styles of fasting the first one was
intermittent fasting which is 12 to 16
hours which is good for weight loss
brain fog that kind of thing
the second is
autography adagi did I say
a photography but I like it
we can play that back I definitely and
if I didn't we'll fix it with AI um
autophagy fasting which is 17 to 72
hours good for balancing sex hormones
and preventing
illness yeah probably yeah number three
we haven't spoken about gut reset fast
yeah what's that yeah so that's based
off a study that came out at MIT that
showed 24 hours without food and your
intestinal stem cells inside your gut
actually start to reboot themselves
now a stem cell is a cell that can go to
anywhere in the body and repair itself
but at 24 hours you get a plethora of
them in your gut
and in the gut we've got a damaged
microbiome from everything that we've
just been talking about
so what I discovered in this 24 hour
fast is I could take women that have
been on birth control pill for years
people that have been on multiple rounds
of antibiotics people who had been
eating horrible food and I could
actually put them through a 24-hour fast
once a week once every couple of weeks
and these stem cells would come in there
and they would start to repair and so
now if I teach that person How to Eat
Right their food is actually starting to
build a better microbiome in the gut
so that 24-hour fast became this go-to
in my clinic where I could take all
these gut challenges and I could start
to unwind them just because I knew the
body had this capability of making these
intestinal stem cells and it was crazy
like we got people off supplements we
got people that were didn't weren't
making serotonin which affects moods
comes from the gut all of a sudden start
to become happier we people who hadn't
had bowel movements in like three days
all of a sudden we started to put in
these this gut reset and it was like a
miracle it was incredible number four
fat burner fast so the fat burner fast
is probably my favorite for those people
who want to lose weight the research was
done that 36 hours without food followed
by 12 hours of eating and then another
third they actually did it over a 30-day
period but we've been using it in our
community just dosing it in
that at 36 hours what happens is that's
enough time where the blood sugars come
come down where all of a sudden the body
it's so smart it goes okay blood sugar
is not common
we've been in this fasted State we've
triggered autophagy we've brought
inflammation down we've made you ketones
we're trying to go find food but this
extra weight it's not serving you you
because remember you gotta go find food
so it drops weight and it's the most
beautiful way to get a person to unstick
any kind of weight loss resistance but
most importantly you know where it
dropped the most amount of weight from
or does everybody want to lose weight
belly yep so it is the I should probably
should have called it the fat burning
belly fat burning belly fat yeah that
would have banged yeah but yeah and so
that's what they showed is that actually
a 36 hour fast started to unstick weight
loss and it was started with weight
around the belly
compelling
number five the dopamine reset fast yeah
so number five
um I found some research showing that
when people go without food for 48 hours
the whole dopamine system will be
rebooted so what's important to know
about the dopamine system is it is our
molecule of happiness it is the thing
that it's actually a motivation molecule
and it's a neurotransmitter that allows
thoughts happy thoughts to go across
from neuron to neuron
and so what happens and I'm sure you've
talked about this on your podcast that
were so dopamine saturated right now but
specifically people who are Overeaters
they actually are finding the study I
quote in the book is that they found
that people who had food addiction
people who had extra weight like obese
situations they were not getting as much
happiness out of their food because
their dopamine receptor sites were
saturated
so they had to eat more food to get more
happiness
and a lot and you know food is a state
changer it does make us happy so what
they found is if they put them into a
48-hour fast that they actually rebooted
the whole dopamine system and new
dopamine receptor sites appeared so that
when they brought food back in to the
equation they actually got more
enjoyment out of food with less food
it's kind of got me thinking about a
conversation I was having yesterday with
some of my team here we were talking
about how
um it almost feels like sometimes if
I've eaten sugar I can go into a bit of
a sugar cycle and what I mean by that is
I'll have some sugar and then like a
couple of hours later I'll have another
craving for sugar and then a couple of
hours later I'll have another craving
for sugar but then other times
specifically for example when I did keto
I was I did the keto diet for about
eight months uh eight weeks bloody eight
months I wish
um eight weeks and throughout that
period I didn't have any cravings for
sugar yep I would we had some chocolate
come into the studio and I walked over
to the chocolate I smelled it
yep and I didn't want any of it yep it
had gone yeah but then when I'm in my
what I call like the sugar cycle I'm
eating sugar maybe you know once or
twice a day and I'm getting like the
craving for it where which I just can't
seem to resist yep
well dopamines the molecule and more
it's not the molecule of enough
so what it does is when you get sugar
you get this dopamine rush and the Brain
goes love that give me more of that and
so you can't you it's it's endless you
will never be fully satisfied it
constantly wants you to come back for
more and more and more so when you start
to go off the ketogenic Energy System
you're getting the same Euphoria you
probably felt the same high the same
mental Clarity but you've totally taken
this molecule more out of the out of the
picture it's it in fact dopamine will
actually you know you you get those
receptor sites that will be repaired but
you're not getting a big dopamine buzz
when you're in a ketogenic State you're
getting ketones I was I was mulling it
with my team how long I had to stay away
from sugar to kind of get out of that
vicious give me more cycle yeah my
experience has been it's about three
days three days that's what I thought
yeah I think I said four or five but
it's just from experience as well if I
haven't had sugar yeah for three or four
days I mean like a like a chocolate or
something significant in terms of sugar
then after three or four days the
craving for it seems to to vanish yeah
yeah it's not it's not if you think
about that it's not hard if you're
trying to overcome a sugar addiction
yeah like just bear it for three days
and then that dopamine stops barking at
you and then if you attack fasting onto
it now you're getting ketones and so
you're not needing that as much ketones
kill hunger and they make you so
mentally mentally clear they give you
this euphoric feeling so you don't have
that urge to go for the for the sugar
and the ketones come from fasting yeah
which is when your body switches
metabolic State go ahead the last and
final
fasting style immune reset fast yeah so
immune reset was built off of Dr Walter
Longo's work and he did a study on
people who had cancer and were going
through chemotherapy and one of the
challenges we know about chemotherapy is
that it wipes out the whole immune
system and so he wanted to see well what
if I put somebody in a fasted State as
they went through chemotherapy would
there be a difference and what he found
is after three days of fasting the white
blood cells in our system actually
reboot themselves so what they do is all
old white blood cells are are sloughed
away and new white blood cells emerge so
people were able to come out of that
chemotherapy experience and have a
stronger immune system as opposed to
what we were seeing was that it was
wiping the immune system out
so that launched the whole three-day
water fast sort of craze at least here
in America we're seeing a lot of people
that are just going after three day
water fast to Prime their immune system
but you also also at three days get stem
cells full systemic stem cells so all of
a sudden your body's got in surging with
stem cells going to all parts of the
body repairing it the great example I
always use on this one was I had an
Achilles tendon injury
and nothing was nothing was helping it
so I threw a five-day water fast at it
on the fourth day I felt this buzz in my
achilles tendon and I was like oh I
wonder what that is and it stayed all
the way through I went five full days
and
um about the fifth and sixth day so
sixth day I was entering food back in
all the pain completely went away and it
never came back
I tried everything I tried everything
and that was the only thing that
repaired it
it does make again evolutionary sense
that
if our body senses were injured because
we're not eating or you know some other
signal that we are
on a course to
not survive to put it nicely
it does make sense that it might set
about to repair whatever needs to be
repaired you're getting it you know
because like if I was a wounded human
back in on the Savannahs of I don't know
Africa or wherever we came from
um and I'm laid there and I'm not eating
my body should probably go okay
Steve might need something fixed so that
he can get back to yeah
hunting so you're getting it so survival
that is the number one priority of the
body
so when you go without food you amplify
every resource it has to keep you alive
and if repairing my achilles means I can
now go hunt for food it's going to do
that it's going to make me stronger
and I in the book I I stumbled when I
was writing the book I stumbled up upon
a really cool hypothesis that's called
the Thrifty Gene hypothesis and it said
that what it's it's a theory obviously
it's a hypothesis it's a theory that the
people the humans that evolved out of
the Primal days had a very specific
genotype and this genotype allowed us to
metabolically flex and and be stronger
in a fasted State because we had to
survive and the people that didn't make
it from that time period didn't have
that Gene
but think about this for this moment so
they think we all have this Gene inside
of us right now this Thrifty Gene where
we can go long periods without food and
we can survive
so what happens when we're eating all
day what happens when we're ignoring and
we're not actually activating that
genetic profile
so what they are now believing is that
diabetes metabolic syndrome all of that
is largely happening because we are
going against the G the genetic profile
that we are now seeing in humans we're
like on the opposite end of this
spectrum
we're overloading our bodies yeah
which is meaning that the survival Genie
reference there is not being activated
to help us that's right
that's right
interesting what about
coffee
you know if I'm gonna fast for I know
people are so addicted to coffee so I
feel like I have to ask a question as
they're representative if I'm gonna fast
do any of these six fasts that you just
mentioned does coffee break that fast
yeah it does break it yeah no well it
depends okay so this is this yes or no
um I can't give you a yes or no that's
fine I'm going to give you most likely
okay no let me give you most likely it's
okay
okay most likely it's okay yes there's
not a high degree of uncertainty and
conviction there no let me let me
explain myself okay so when you drink a
cup of coffee it shouldn't spike your
blood sugar
it shouldn't should not it doesn't
so if it does it shouldn't so if you
have black coffee and your blood sugar
doesn't Spike and you're you're trying
to metabolically switch over into your
fasting window
you're good you're golden drink that
black coffee okay okay now I'm gonna add
some sugar to it
okay now now you're not switch now
you've pulled you've pulled yourself out
of fasted State uh okay so no sugar just
a plain coffee with no milk or sugar in
it is most
most likely uh well I've seen a few
occasions where it didn't okay um this
is why we have people test their blood
sugar like it it's Unique to you so you
can test your blood sugar have the cup
of coffee half an hour later check your
blood sugar again those numbers should
be equal okay so for most people coffee
should be fine when they're fasting yes
but there's a couple of anomalies who
their blood sugar does Spike yes um
which means that they're not going to
switch over to the fasted State yes yes
exactly and you know Coffee-Mate
creamers
um those can be a little more
problematic but some people put full fat
cream in there with no sugar some people
put MCT oil in there you know the
buttered coffee became very very common
and that was because of the fasting
movement so the reason they did that was
because when you put a fat in your
coffee you stabilized your blood sugar
and so you were able to stay in the
fasted State and switch over I had
glucose goddess on the podcast who um
Jesse she talks a lot about glucose
bikes it was the first time my eyes were
really open to the consequence of living
a life where your glucose levels are
spiking and crashing and spiking and
crashing and I've invested in this
company called Zoe where they give you a
glucose monitor which I attached my arm
for 14 days as part of the initial test
and then they give me this big sort of
nutrition plan and profile and um that
was the first time I got to see you know
I was in America at the time I was in LA
for a couple of months and I
in La I mean I pulled up at a gas
station and I was when I was walking
through this gas station and everything
in there was sugar yeah because because
now I was looking right now I had my
eyes open because I'm wearing this
bloody monitor yeah so I'm about to see
the impact within minutes that it has on
my body and I was just looking around
thinking oh my God
the only thing that I can see in this
whole store that I can eat without
spiking my glucose is water so is it a
monitor where you can see it you can
scan it yeah yeah so so they've got game
changer yeah so they've got two one of
them you scan the new one they've got
it's automatic Yeah by Bluetooth so it
just keeps constantly updating on your
phone
I honestly think we could dramatically
change the health of the world if
everybody put one of those on Amen amen
because then what you would do is you
would just go because I you know this is
like coffee like you should it should be
so simple for me just to say yes drink
your coffee you're fine but your
microbiome in your gut is going to
determine what it does with whatever
hits that so it's going to determine
your blood sugar levels your microbiome
my microbiome completely different so
food no longer is a one size fits all
there's an individual approach so you
have to know what your blood sugar is
doing yeah you know like when I eat
believe it or not when I eat a grass-fed
steak my blood sugar goes down
it's amazing wow so whereas other people
eat a steak and their blood sugar goes
super high
and so then again you go to a thread of
this conversation which is how do we
help Humanity yeah and Humanity wants
the one-size-fits all
I can't give you that yeah you're gonna
have to learn your own you got to learn
you
and something like that teaches you you
but you're gonna have to become very
curious about you like you are and
what's really fun to me when you put one
of those things on it's my favorite
thing to do with patients is I say just
eat normal just eat everything yeah yeah
yeah and then and then every day I have
them send me their readings and we just
talk it through I I just did this with a
beautiful patient that I've been working
with who has a long history of eating
disorders
and she was counting calories and
um really wanted the control of being
able to keep her weight where she was
where it needed to be and I said okay
you can count calories if you want but I
just want you to stick this monitor on
and let's just eat and let's see what
you're doing and she was vegan and this
is in a this isn't an anti-vegan
conversation but her spikes were up and
down and up and down like there was like
eight of them a day
and her moods followed those spikes too
and so then we started to go okay well
let's add a protein here could we add
fat here could we add some more fiber
here and she got to watch for herself
and within four weeks she was free of
any food control and she was off
teaching everybody else it was so
beautiful to watch back calorie counting
point though
there's a there's a big school of
thought that in order to lose weight and
be healthy all you've got to do is count
those calories
there's something called a set
yeah which is the amount of calories
that I need to consume in order to hit
my that's right so we all have a set
point if you're going to go down the
calorie path
you you have to understand you have a
set point and the set point is there's a
mo how much calories coming in and how
much calories going out what's the Delta
of that and that will keep you at
whatever weight you want to be so let's
use an example you eat 1500 calories a
day you exercise 500 you have a Delta of
a thousand so if you want to keep your
weight where it's at you always have to
do a thousand calories every single day
yeah okay well what happens on the days
you decide not to work out
so now you have 500 extra calories that
your body's not used to and so what does
it do with those calories
stores it so then you all of a sudden
start noticing you're gaining weight you
don't really understand why so you're
like well let me count I need to
restrict calories yeah so then you start
eating maybe I mean I have 500 less yeah
and then you bring the set point down
well that's your new that's your new set
point you're gonna have to stay at that
set point now if you don't ever want to
gain another pound
you see the game oh okay so my set point
is moving the crafty it moves because as
you restrict and you if as food
restriction goes down and energy output
goes up your set point goes down and now
you're like I feel great but you can't
leave from that set point you're going
to always have to make sure that that
set point is a thousand calories or 800
calories so I was told I mean this is
the school of thought that I have to
have
for me as a male that has my weight 2
000 calories a day and then if I'm under
2000 calories a day then I'll lose
weight that's what I was told yeah so
you go now you go to 500 calories
up weight yeah to lose the weight yep
you go back up to 2 000 and for most
people they start to gain weight again
because my my set point has moved yeah
so now it's 1 500 yeah to maintain my
weight yeah which is why if you found it
have we have we ever seen a calorie
restriction diet work long term
no
no I haven't
long term being the key word there yeah
term it works great but this is why I'm
such a fan of metabolic switching how
about we watch blood sugar we put a
monitor like you're talking let's put a
monitor on so that you keep your blood
sugar spikes minimal it's like what I
did with this woman is I was like let's
can we have two two spikes in a day not
eight and we just keep your blood sugar
at a at a low level so that when you're
not eating you can switch over and now
you can burn fat in the fat burning
Energy System
so metabolic switching is where you're
keeping your blood sugar at a stable
place it's not got all these Spikes all
over the place so that when it starts to
go down the body is going to want to
switch over and it can start to burn fat
in the in and use that other Energy
System what do you think our
relationships should be with sugar
well you know there's only 12 percent of
Americans that are metabolically healthy
as that means that they have the right
blood pressure the right cholesterol
that their hemoglobin A1c their insulin
all those metabolic markers are in
Balance only 12 percent of Americans
have that right
that is a huge problem
and that is largely because we're
addicted to sugar
so what's the consequence of poor
metabolic health
obesity cancer heart disease mental
health challenges I mean you name it
every chronic disease on the planet at
the root has a metabolic thread now I
hate to bring back a a really traumatic
concept uh topic but during covet
when we looked at the people that fell
prey to covid this is no no disrespect
they were metabolically unhealthy
and the people that had less coveted
symptoms were the ones that were more
metabolically healthy in general
so and largely because the virus could
grow could really replicate if you had a
lot of glucose in your system
so the consequence is huge and the
health care Consequence the amount of
money we pay trying to help everybody
put their health back together because
they're metabolically unhealthy if we
just started with metabolic Health we
would change everything and metabolic
Health people think of metabolic Health
often as being
you know I'm in good
superficial shape
I'd like to think
um but that's not metabolic Health you
could be I'm guessing you can be
metabolically unhealthy but also
have abs oh oh yeah you could this woman
I was telling you about with all the
spikes she was she's actually a model
and an actress oh wow that that is
beautiful and we had to go back in and
really work with getting her
metabolically healthy so yeah you could
we call it skinny fat you look you look
skinny on the outside but you're dealing
with excess sugar on the inside that is
putting fat around your liver putting
fat in other areas I think a lot of
people can relate to that skinny fat
yeah yeah
so it's it's a major major issue and and
you know we can look at different things
like hemoglobin A1c it's a marker in the
blood everybody gets it tested every
year when they go to their doctor it
should be under five
if it's not under five what's happening
is all that extra sugar is is going
around your red blood cells and your red
blood cells carry oxygen to your body so
they're gummed up with sugar so they
can't deliver things oxygen to the brain
to your eyes to your muscle so you're
not getting oxygenated because of the
sugar just gumming up these red blood
cells
in chapter one of your book you talk
about this um metabolic Health crisis in
great detail you share some stats which
I pulled out which I I thought were
terrifying it's page page four of your
book you say according to the CDC 41 of
women and 21 and older are obese 45 have
high blood pressure out of two one out
of two will develop cancer in their
lifetimes one out of five will develop
Alzheimer's one out of nine will get
type 2 diabetes one out of eight will
develop a thyroid problem and eighty
percent of all autoimmune conditions
occur in women
why is that that last one eighty percent
of all autoimmune conditions occur in
women yeah so autoimmunity is a really
interesting one
um and um if you look at what an
autoimmune condition is it's the body
attacking itself
and so when we look at where toxins go
or back of the toxins Hashimoto's why is
the body attacking the thyroid there's
something there that needs to get out so
it's usually a toxic issue so the body's
attacking the the thyroid when we look
at ra and Joints there's toxins in their
bodies attacking that so it's happening
more to women largely because well this
is this this could go dark real fast but
largely because we have so many
influences that are affecting our our
hormones so the best way I can explain
this is something I call the hormonal
hierarchy where our sex hormones are
going to be completely thrown off by
insulin
so when you get insulin resistant your
sex hormones are off and insulin is
going to be so impacted by cortisol so
when you're stressed all the time you're
going to be insulin resistant and when
your insulin is insulin resistant you're
going to have trouble balancing estrogen
progesterone and testosterone but at the
top of the hierarchy is oxytocin an
oxytocin is that we're getting oxytocin
right now just from connecting with each
other and it'll calm start to calm
cortisol down and then when it calms
cortisol down you can be more insulin
sensitive and when you can be more
insulin sensitive now your sex hormones
can can balance better
so we need that hierarchy as as women to
be in balance in order for our bodies to
be in balance
but what do we have women doing right
now we have poor diet lots of stress
uh and our sex hormones are way off
which and sugar you're good after the
sugar yeah so women are are perishing
within this modern world more than men
so we've got to help a woman bring back
more insulin sensitive sensitivity we
got to get her doing better Stress
Management and when we do that now the
immune system can regulate now the
immune system can calm down and stop
being so hyperactive attacking all the
toxins that are in the body so it's very
complex does not imply that women and
men have a different relationship with
stress oh yeah yeah
yeah for sure we're not I okay so I'm
gonna I'm gonna be as bold as to say
this and I know all my my feminist women
out there are not gonna like this and I
I was raised by a strong woman I am a
strong woman I've raised just another
strong woman and I have to tell you that
we are not meant to handle the stress
loads as well as men
and that's largely because of two
hormones so estrogen makes us very out
outward makes us very much an extrovert
and we can handle a lot of stress when
when estrogen is present in our body but
progesterone
she can't handle stress at all so
progesterone will start to diminish as
cortisol goes up I always say when
cortisol goes High progesterone becomes
shy
so now we're I mean the number of women
since fast like a girl came out that I
have heard from the 20 and 30 year olds
that have no cycle none
that is because they're insulin
resistant they're more stressed
progesterone's not making her appearance
so there's no shed of the uterine lining
that is absolutely a stress issue and
not having a period for a woman is a
major problem because that's how we
detox that's how we get these hormones
out of us
so if you're not having a cycle you're
not getting rid of estrogen you're not
getting rid of so many toxins and it's
just staying inside of you
that's that's a major problem
controversial idea but it rings true for
a lot of people yeah and I know this
because I've had women very close to me
in my life talk to me about this exact
thing and um
specifically not having their menstrual
cycle and then
focusing on the stresses in their life
and then their menstrual cycle coming
back
um people very very close to me in fact
that I've I've struggled with because of
this exact challenge
it is a controversial idea though isn't
it it's a it's slightly problematic
um as an idea is there any scientific
basis for that idea well we know based
off science that when cortisol goes up
progesterone goes down cortisol is the
stress hormone yeah so when you're under
stress cortisol goes up and so if you're
let's say it's the week before your
period That's when you're supposed to
have the most amount of progesterone if
it doesn't matter if you're trying to
run a marathon doesn't matter if you
have a work deadline doesn't matter if
you're skimping on sleep as long as
cortisol is going up progesterone is not
going to make her appearance and if she
doesn't make her appearance then the
uterine lining won't shed that's that's
been proven over and over every hormone
expert would agree multiple studies but
women don't realize that
so we if there's ever a time to mind
your stress it's the week before your
period which is why you don't fast the
week before your period because that's a
that's a bit of a stressor it's why you
shouldn't train for you know a big
Spartan Race or a cross-fitting event or
run a marathon you should be doing more
yoga and Recovery the week before your
period this is why we should prioritize
sleep the week before our periods
because that we don't want cortisol up
so in a in an interesting world this is
sort of the vision I have for women
right now is what if there is this
moment where the week before our period
we have the capability of maybe not
working as hard there like Spain they're
giving a three-day menstrual leave to
women
they with no questions asked before the
before the period Well it's no questions
asked they anticipated it that women
would use it the first three days of her
period but a woman can use it anytime I
say use it the three days before your
cycle is supposed to come
interesting Have you shared this idea
before publicly uh I've on several
podcasts I've talked about it I had a
great interview with Kate Northrup on my
podcast and she's an entrepreneur and
she actually Maps her whole business
cycle around her menstrual cycle and so
we had a beautiful conversation about
this and she said that she doesn't do as
many Zoom calls she tells her team that
she's going to take get get off work a
little bit earlier on those days she
slows everything down her workload goes
dramatically down and she said what
ended up happening is that when her
period started her productivity went up
so see what when estrogen comes in on on
starting day one day two of our
menstrual cycles estrogen makes us
really mentally clear makes us very
verbal estrogen is an incredible hormone
for productivity
but if you aren't minding that back half
of your cycle and you're not slowing
down then
then you're coming into your period and
you're having you hear so many women who
are like I'm cramping I'm bleeding a lot
it's really painful that's because you
didn't mind the back half of your cycle
and what's the sort of evolutionary
basis for all of this why is the body
doing this why is the body
um not going to give us our periods I
mean listen I don't have a period but um
well I have a version of it right I'm
sure men have some yeah you guys you
guys have a you work off a 24-hour cycle
okay so every 15 minutes you get
testosterone okay you know we joke about
that right what do you say you strip
behind our backs
okay what'd you say the joke is because
like if you don't like what your
husband's saying just ask him in 15
minutes he might say something different
oh that's what you've been saying just
letting you in on what might be going on
behind the scenes Okay so
what is the evolutionary basis for why
why that is true
so think about the ads let's go back to
our Primal days so you know testosterone
is meant to have you go out and hunt at
some very motivating it's you get it
every 15 minutes so you know God this
sounds as I'm saying it sounds so sexist
but when we look at the body this is
actually how we're built so you were
your body was driven to go hunt and go
find and Go Achieve that's the number
one hormone that it works off of
for the women
what are we are meant to be more
outgoing before ovulation okay why is
that
oh we need to connect we need to start
to feel that that mental Clarity you
know estrogen makes your hair really
like full and your skin really glow and
it starts to make us more beautiful all
leading up to to ovulation
once ovulation hits now we have estrogen
at our Peak we have a little bit of
testosterone and we have a little bit of
progesterone okay well why is that
because now our libidos up we're
motivated to reproduce we're looking
beautiful because we have so much
estrogen going through our body we're
verbal we can connect and we have
progesterone to keep us calm
so we're supposed to reproduce when
ovulation hits
and then the back half
technically we would be have a
fertilized egg and we would be winding
down
and if we didn't get a fertilized egg
then we're supposed to relax so we can
go back and do the extroverted piece of
ourselves in the front half of our cycle
so it's all based off of reproduction so
I need some advice then because I'm in a
relationship and I want to understand
I guess this goes both ways I want my
girlfriend to understand how hormones
are influencing my behavior and I want
to know how hormones are influencing her
behavior yeah what advice have you got
for me well the first is do you know her
cycle
moving on we're going to talk about
sugar again no no this is too good
so sugar it's really bad isn't it who's
to blame no seriously tell me about your
childhood
recycled I'm going to give you I'm going
to give you
let me give you gold
okay so day one of her cycle day one to
day 10 she's building estrogen first
couple of days of her cycle just let her
be like she you know that she's
transitioning out of the back half of
her cycle she might be having some
heavier bleeding you know she's moving
into that extroverted place so the first
two days give her some space now day
three estrogen is starting to to build
so you're going to notice she's more
verbal she's going to be more present
she might feel more outgoing she's going
to feel like she wants to connect with
you that's gonna go all the way through
ovulation like in the middle of
ovulation which is about day 12 day 13
where all of a sudden estrogens at its
peak if you have any conflict you want
to resolve with her do it between like
day two and day 12 of her cycle
she's going to be so ready to handle any
conflict with you between let me write
that down
day two and day 12. day two like
literally at my battles I had a I had a
dad come to me and tell me that he was
struggling to understand his teenage
daughter and I said well do you know our
cycle
and he's like no I don't I said well you
would never ever bring a conflict to her
on day 18 or 19 of her cycle bring it to
her on day 10 and now she's going to
talk to you
I'm gonna say something which is really
embarrassing here I know nothing about
menstrual cycles at no point in my life
did anybody teach me about menstrual
cycles the only
Insight I have in my life to what a
menstrual cycle is is overhearing my
sister when I was younger
talking about it yeah and when I say
overhearing I mean maybe a sentence and
then maybe my girlfriend once in a while
she'll say oh I'm coming into my cycle
or whatever she's home on my period
that's for most men that's in fact the
extent of the education we have about
the female reproductive
um mental menstrual cycles yep so talk
to me like I'm an idiot about the
menstrual cycle yeah how long is it oh I
loved it and do you know that most women
don't know oh really so I mean most
women are ignorant to their own Cycles
so it's 28 days anywhere from 28 days to
32 every woman has a different length
okay and what day does the period come
on day one so day one is the first day
she bleeds okay then how long that lasts
for what seven days uh everyone's
different anywhere from three to seven
days okay
so they you said day between day two and
twelve is when to yeah pick my battles
yeah so day two you're gonna start to
see her be emerge a little more
gregarious she may be a little more
outgoing so I mean as she get closer to
day 12 you wanna go party with her you
want to take her out make her feel good
like that's the time to wine and dine
her okay cool we'll put all the dates
then and have a fights and then after
day 12 what am I doing then after date
well okay so day 12 is right when she's
ovulating so you're gonna have to choose
your battle there but ovulation occurs
for most women between day 10 and day
15. there's a small little five day
window there that's if this is the one
once I figured this out I was like why
don't why don't men know this
um that's when she's going to be her
libido is going to be the highest okay
so we're having sex yes so if you want
to have sex with her let's write this
down yeah have sex with her around that
time around that time she's willing yeah
she's going to be more motivated because
she has testosterone she's going to feel
more like it okay then after she
finishes ovulating after day 15. yeah so
then there's gonna be a crash of
hormones you might see a change in her
personality she might feel a little low
so let's go stay in a hotel
but you could ask
like if she's having a bummer day like
or a low day ask her do you know what
day or cycle are you on be really nice
be really nice
and then here's the gold here's gold
this is so good you're gonna have to
report back to me how this works okay uh
when around day 17 or 18 progesterone's
coming in this is where you got to give
her foot rubs you gotta be extra special
and cater her like like she's the queen
that she deserves to be okay so all my
compliments that's where I pull out the
notepad
but what you need to know is she's
probably gonna be like if you're like oh
you look so beautiful today she might at
that time be like no I feel horrible I'm
bloated I'm I don't feel beautiful but
you know I should disagree I should say
no no you you're no you don't you look
amazing okay cool
and you do that until she bleeds and you
can take amazing care of her in the back
the week before her period and you will
get kudos like you you can't even
imagine and then start it all over again
and then start it all over again
yeah I mean just once you understand our
patterns and then it also helps you
understand that we're going to be more
outgoing in the front half of our cycle
we're gonna be more introverted in the
back half what about men
you guys every 15 minutes you you're
pretty you're pretty black and white
really yeah you're pretty
straightforward
so if she was asking you the same
question about me would you say anything
to her about my hormone Cycles at all
you'd you just say well it really
depends on the issue at hand so if it's
a um a mismatch of libido then the best
time to have sex with a woman is during
ovulation okay because she has the most
amount of testosterone day 10-15 yeah it
would be really handy wouldn't it just
to have a little menstrual cycle chart
on the wall at home I know that sounds a
bit strange but just so I know yeah
what's going on inside her body I the
first time I discovered this I started
using an app called The Clue app yeah
and it shows you in a circle it kind of
shows a little cloud and then it shows
you where PMs Clicks in and it actually
has a button that you can share it with
people in your life and I thought not
only does my husband need this but my
staff needs this they need to understand
where I'm going and what if all the
women on my on my team actually shared
it with each other and we could see
where each other was at in the menstrual
cycle we would understand why a woman's
moods can be so up and down it's really
you know it because of these three
hormones
our moods are much more volatile than
yours you guys are pretty steady Eddie
we're I mean this is general you know
this is I hate to be
sexist in this conversation but this is
hormones than the way they work it's
actually really helpful to know this
because without this Insight it's very
easy to fall into the Trap of just
assuming
your partner is Moody or that they are
they have like mood swings or that
they're you know people say things like
they're too emotional or they're
whatever it might be but with this I
actually think it creates a ton of
empathy yeah that's certainly the
reaction that I get from hearing that
there's a there's significant hormone
fluctuations in my partner and they
happen at certain periods it actually
now
would change my behavior the way that I
receive certain times where I come home
or I'm I noticed that my my partner's
just different and it's almost it
catches me off guard sometimes I've
actually we've spoken a lot about this
and we're very open we're very much the
same person in terms of our willingness
to talk about everything
um and very difficult things as well
yeah and there will be times where
um I come home or we go through a patch
where just a week you know things are
making her upset which wouldn't normally
make her upset just tiny things that I'm
doing
and I go what that's it you know so see
if you can track that to a certain part
of our cycle oh I'm kidding so like the
week before our period we're pretty
we're irritable and every time I say
that men go well you said it I didn't
say it well but that's because
progesterone we you know we're meant to
be more inner we're meant to sit on the
couch we're also meant Believe It or Not
glucose goes higher the week before our
period so We crave carbs there's a
reason We crave carbs because we need to
bring glucose up to be able to make
progesterone
so We crave carbs we're irritable we
don't want a lot of cortisol so
generally we're a little bit slower we
don't want to you know we don't have the
desire to push through stress and push
through exercise and so we're gonna be
we're a little we're different that week
where so if you come up and you just put
your hand on our shoulder and you're
like I love you you're amazing I'm here
if you need anything
that's all you got to do but if you're
trying to resolve a big conflict or
you're trying to come at us in in too
aggressive away we will shut down the
week before our periods
so interesting
whereas if you have something you want
to resolve with us make sure estrogen's
there because estrogen makes us great
great verbal our verbal skills are
incredible when estrogens round ask any
menopausal woman she'll tell you what
it's like when she loses estrogen and I
have to say this is because you know
women have this incredible power to
create life yeah yeah that us men don't
have it's like women are superheroes for
being able to carry a baby for
significant amounts of time and then
give birth to this baby it's just the
most magical thing that I can think of
in existence and women have that
superpower and with that comes this
cycle yeah so it's a wonderful thing
it's beautiful and in in
I called it the manifestation 's
ovulation big
when all of those hormones come in
we can manifest anything we want
but it's not just a baby this is a great
time ovulation is an amazing time to
start a new business project interesting
it's a great time like as an author like
I'm gonna write during those five days
because my creativity is going to be at
its peak
so we're highly creative if you want to
like you know talk about something about
life and how to create something with us
do it during ovulation your husband
behind that wall here in my home
and just is he aware of your menstrual
cycle he he is until I started to lose
it I'm 53 so I'm starting to go
um but yeah we talk like this all the
time and and the way I like to to I like
to take ownership over my hormonal moods
so I will say to him after a long day of
work I will say hey it's been a
testosterone driven day for me
I don't feel like I have a lot of
estrogen right now I can't handle a lot
of stress I'm gonna need to just take
some time to myself
we literally talk like that
we um
losing the menstrual cycle we the first
time I started as a young man that
hasn't been exposed to that at any point
in my sort of you know in the education
system or other
um the first time I started to
understand what menopause was and
pre-menopause and perimenopause all
these things was from guests that have
come here yeah and it's such a big it
was such a big light bulb moment for me
because I have women in my life that are
going through that phase of Life yeah
I feel like they are so misunderstood in
so many ways thank you and I love
hearing about it now
um because it's going to help me relate
to those women in a better way and have
and understand how I can be
a partner with them through that phase
of life like you know certain members of
my family that are going through that
phase of life
what do what do we need to know as men
but also as women about menopause
perimenopause and all those things yeah
thank you thank you for asking I think
we're the most misunderstood
um age group of women and with the 45 to
55 year old in that decade is the most
common time for women to commit suicide
really yeah
this is why my next book I'm writing
right now is on the mental health of
menopausal women because we're
struggling
and so the first thing you have to know
is that after 40 our sex hormones start
to decline
so estrogen goes up and down so one day
you're gonna experience if you have if
you live with a 43 year old woman you're
gonna experience she's great next day
you're gonna be like who are you that's
because her estrogen is on a roller
coaster ride so that's the first thing
to know
second thing is that progesterone is
plummeting after 40. they actually say
now at 35 progesterone is starting to go
down
so as progesterone goes down we are less
stress resilient so little things are
going to irritate us like they've never
irritated us before and you might be the
recipient of that
so if you find we're very triggerable
it's because we're losing progesterone
so
we need to we just need to have more
breaks we need more nurturing like I
explained in the menstrual cycle we need
to have more love brought our way
because we just can't handle stress the
same way
and then as as ultimately estrogen
finally goes into a place where she's
non-existent once a woman doesn't have
her cycle we can't hold on to
information the way the same way we used
to be able to we forget things and it's
really frustrating to us and so when
people around us like I went through
this with my team when I was trying to
get my menopausal hormones in check they
would say well you already told us that
yes you reminded us of that and I
started finding I was repeating myself
and then I realized oh I'm at a noon
level of low of estrogen and then I
worked you know getting I'm working with
some bioidenticals working with some
lifestyle to bring my estrogen up but
from 40 to about 55
that is about a 10 to 15 year period
where the woman's brain has to
recalibrate to these loss of hormones
and so our moods are all over the place
during that time so understanding where
we're at having more compassion for us
not taking us on
um and just helping us understand
ourselves which is largely what I'm
trying to do through my books is will be
so helpful but we don't even understand
our own selves menopausal moods are are
treacherous it's an extreme sport
it literally is an extreme sport what
about after 45 she said 40 to 45 yeah so
once we actually go a whole year without
a period
we actually do better
so the brain is used to the less
hormones so when we get on the other
side postmenopausal we actually are
great uh we're women that once they go
to that side of the hormonal process
tend to actually be you know we have so
much wisdom I'd like to think
um we actually tend to be the opposite
of everything I just said we tend to be
more stress uh we can handle stress
better we tend to be more gregarious our
libido goes back up our as our brain
starts to recalibrate we become a better
version of ourselves
and that's that first phase that 40 to
45 phase what's that phase called is
that the that's perimenopause
perimenopause and then menopause is
beyond 45 yeah with the average age for
menopause right now is about 52 although
a lot of women are going in around 45
sometimes earlier
but but I think that if there was one
thing I want one I could help the world
understand is that we're trying to
understand ourselves during that time so
be patient with us
because we may not we may react much
different than you've ever seen us react
before
so we have to get to know ourselves from
a new lens that's the gift that
menopause actually gives us
and if you allow us to do that when we
make it through to the post-menopausal
years you're going to have a beautiful
wise wonderful woman on the other side
of that it's just that transition into
perimenopause is really a treacherous
one
so interesting it's so I find it
staggering that no one told me this at
any point in my life agreed because
irrespective of whether you are a woman
or not and you're going to go through
that you're going to
um your relationships with women are
going to be integral to your life
unavoidably your mother your grandmother
your partner so having the Insight gives
me the empathy I love it you know and
that's what that's why I'm so fortunate
from having this conversation it was
Gabby Logan who came on this podcast
Davina McCall who wrote a book about
menopause in the end I knew that I've
really helped to open my eyes about that
and um
it's interesting I don't know what it is
I think growing up like men just don't
want to talk about periods and menstrual
cycles and all of these kinds of things
they're almost taboo yeah in a weird way
I call it in the new book I'm right now
I'm calling it the cultural hush yeah I
think we have a cultural hush around the
menstrual cycle around menopause I can't
tell you the number of men since fast
like a girl that has come out that read
that book and they go to the chapter on
women and hormones and then they come
and find me and say I finally understand
my wife yeah I finally understand my
daughter why aren't we talking about
that and then how many women we don't we
don't talk about like the fact that I'm
I'm suffering because I don't have as
much estrogen it would we don't have a
culture or society that allows us to
talk like that and that's what I think
is Shifting right now so many menopause
books are coming out big people you know
Oprah's starting to do a whole thing on
menopause like the conversation's
opening up but it's going to take
bravery from women then to step up I
mean I'm a very very capable woman who
has a beautiful family and a great
business it's really hard for me to say
I can't do one more zoom call my brain
can't do it that feels like failure
and then we have the other side of this
which is we have the men that are like
why are you being a today
It's like because I don't have the
hormone to stop me from being a
today
so those those kind of conversations are
not hand happening but if we did it with
more empathy if we could express
ourselves like hey I just need I need a
break right now is just a lot on my
hormones give me 30 minutes give me an
hour I can come back and be a better
version I just need to take care of
myself now someone's going to be
listening to this and they're going to
think it's not a problem you can just go
get the hormones you can just go get
some HRT
it's called HRT right HRT yeah you can
go get some HRT throw that at the
problem then you'll have your hormones
back yeah
so this is this is the big thing is that
just because you take a hormone doesn't
mean your cells are going to use it
so if you take it let's use let's use uh
thyroid it's a perfect example because
so many women specifically take thyroid
medication and they don't see any any
change in their thyroid symptoms
it's called an exogenous hormone you
bring it into your body
the body registers that it's there the
gut and the liver have to still break
that hormone down into a usable form so
if your gut is off or your liver is
overloaded you're not going to break
that hormone down
once that hormone's broken down the cell
has to be able to receive it if that
cell is inflamed with a lot of toxic
oils and endocrine disruptors there's no
way to get the hormone into the cell
so there are three very pivotal pieces
you gotta there has to be production of
the hormone there has to be breaking
down in the hormone and there has to be
a receiving of the hormone so when you
take HRT you're only handling one of
those things you still and lifestyle
this is why I'm such a so passionate
about lifestyle lifestyle can handle the
other two they can take care of the gut
and the liver they can open up the cell
so it can receive HRT I I've been I
wrote a book called The menopause reset
and it'll come out and we're reissuing
it in June and one of the things in
there is I I mapped out five lifestyle
changes that women should do after 40.
and in that book I lived that I did that
through my whole 40s I didn't start
doing bioidenticals till like 52 but I
had my lifestyle dialed in first and now
bioidenticals are working well
people are sat there going five
Lifestyle Changes
they want to know what they are they're
gonna they're gonna buy the book as well
aren't we we're gonna buy the book and
we're gonna find out right now yes okay
well what do you think the first one is
fasting yes there you go the first one's
fasting uh so and actually fast like a
girl came after the menopause reset
because all the women asked me well what
if I have a site you know what if I'm in
my 30s what if I'm in my 20s how should
I fast so that's you know that was sort
of the birth of that book so fasting
second one is you have to learn to cycle
your food so you ketogenic diet works
really well
at certain times cycle your food cycle
your food Styles what does that mean so
it if in the front half if you have a
menstrual cycle yeah in the front half
when estrogen's coming in go keto keep
carbs low keep glucose low you're great
back half of your cycle when
progesterone is coming in raise glucose
so don't go keto but do Nature's carbs
do more fruits do more squashes potatoes
that's going to help with building
progesterone so the perimenopausal woman
has to learn that there's times to bring
carbs down and there's times to bring
carbs up and that's what I explained in
that I called it keto variations in that
book so that's step two
step three microbiome you got to pay
attention to your microbiome too many
women have been on birth control for
decades they go screaming into their
perimenopausal years and their
microbiomes and is completely off we
have a whole set of bacteria in our gut
called the estrobolome which is the
bacteria that break estrogen down so you
need to be eating more leafy green
vegetables more nuts and seeds olives
chocolate even is great for the
microbiome so I list all those Foods out
in there and then number go ahead and
that's for stage two of the three steps
to actually these hormone replacement
therapies actually working which is
being able to metabolize the hormone
break it down yes you got it okay yeah
you got it you're gonna be a hormone
expert after this well you know it's
just a pretty face yeah so then the
fourth one is watch your toxic love so
we talked about that and then step five
is my favorite
um and it's stopped being a rushing
woman
yeah I know as I tell you from a rushing
lifestyle
we need more as we go through
perimenopause we need more more downtime
you got to schedule more downtime you
need to let that nervous system come
down you can't go through your
perimenopausal years and Thrive if you
are a go go all the time it will catch
up with you and so you've got to bring
in more mindfulness more meditation more
yoga more more vacations more no's
that's got to be a part of your
repertoire you might have gotten away
with it at 35 but you won't get away
with it at 45.
I was thinking then as you're speaking I
was thinking about how I kind of
summarize all of these points into how
we should be living Our Lives as men and
women because obviously we've got
dragged into a consumerist workaholic
sugar overloaded toxin-ridden life
because of because we've been
unconscious yeah you know so that's the
way that
corporations and media narrative and
social media algorithms have taken us so
I was thinking if we could just pause
for a second and we could rewrite the
blueprint of what it is to be a human
and how to live
let's try and rewrite that so how would
I work as a man and a woman what would
be the differences how many days a week
what if you if you were in charge now
rewriting that which you might be one
day
so how would men and women work and and
you mean from a business yeah like a
professional standpoint okay well let's
start with a man yeah so well both men
and women have we have two nervous
systems one that speeds us up one that
relax that slows us down
so you could be in a speed up mode most
of the time I would say you just need to
make sure I mean it really actually I
just thought about this right now
the the patriarchal Work Week works
really well for men
Monday through Friday Friday work your
fanny off Saturday and Sunday take it
off now you're you're moving in and out
of your parasympathetic and sympathetic
nervous system and you're giving both of
them a break you are not meant to be
working 24 7 7 days a week you know like
you're not meant to be working all the
time and and never taking a break what
would you make the work hours for man
well I'm I'm a big fan of working in the
daylight and resting we're supposed to
rest when it's dark okay so winter you
would work less summer you would work
more okay we do the opposite right we
take more vacation in the summer
women
so women we would design our whole work
week around our menstrual cycle so we
could go Full Tilt all the way till day
19 day 20 and then we would we would
take a week off
and we would bow out
so instead of doing it in a weekly
amount like you guys would be doing we'd
be doing it in a monthly amount and how
long would you bow out for
well ideally it depends on each woman is
going to be a little different but I
would say anywhere from I want to say
seven days if it worked for a schedule
until you bleed so day 20 till you know
if you're if day 21 until day 28 you
would do it for a week Bowie now might
also look like
I just am not going to take on the the
high load that I normally do the rest of
the month maybe I'll cut it in half
maybe work from home or yeah maybe I
work from home maybe I can't do my
workload and my extreme exercise and go
socialize with my friends during that
week I just need to start to slow
everything down so that's what I want to
say about bowing out is that it's just
you're putting yourself first and you're
slowing everything down now eating
men and women eating yeah so men
um I think as far as food I agree with
just keeping blood sugar stable is great
I think you guys really work well off of
a meat based and animal diet I don't
think you have more you have more
testosterone which means you have more
muscle we the way that we build muscle
and keep muscle strong is through amino
acids and you get that in meat so for
men I feel like that Primal diet the
paleo diet was meat and vegetables and
fruit is amazing I think that's that's
perfect I don't think refined flowers
and sugars that we are exposed to I
think that over and over abundance
they'll hurt men too and we're seeing
that with metabolic syndrome
women
we do well with meats you know I think
we need less of it because we have less
testosterone
so we may need less of it although it is
important protein is important
especially as we age so I don't want to
lose sight on that but we also need to
bring glucose up so we need more fruits
we're going to need more squashes we're
going to need more potatoes and that's
you know all built around your menstrual
cycle so eating times
I'm I'm not a fan of eating when it's
dark out because when melatonin goes up
insulin you become more insulin
resistant
so I'm a fan of which means well it
means you so your your body won't
process the glucose from that meal as
efficiently when it's dark out it won't
take it away in store yeah there's
energy exactly it will store it as fat
or something yeah it's going to store it
as fat if it can't if insulin can't
drive it into the cell for energy it'll
start as fat so the meal you eat at 9 30
is going to be stored more as fat than
if you have that same meal at 5 30.
I know so 90 says aren't doing
themselves any favors no
so we go back to our Primal friends
right like let's go back and use that if
if people get lost in these theories so
they didn't have electricity they sat
around the fire
so most likely they ate during light
hours
and then the women what did the women do
if we go back and look at cultures
around our period we were actually
that's the whole Red Tent ideas we were
sequestered off into another part of the
of the tribe we didn't have to do as
many chores we went more into an
introverted place if you go back and you
study what we did in those days it was
very much along those lines
and we're just not doing that now
what about supplements what supplements
would you have men and women consuming
uh well for women the most important
supplements she could ever take is
magnesium
magnesium makes every single hormone in
your body
for men I would say the most important
supplement I mean there's a lot of them
but for hormones zinc because zinc makes
testosterone
outside of that for both men and women
the other supplement and the other
measurement that we all need to be
looking at are vitamin D levels yeah
I've learned this from guessing this
podcast I started taking Vitamin D
supplements yeah if your vitamin D is
under 30 you are in a critically
depressed immune state
uh so you got to get it definitely over
30. for hormonal Health we need to see
it more up in about 60 70 to have your
hormones be working at their best
so this this goes back to like the HRT
thing if all if we're taking HRT but our
vitamin D is 20. that HRT isn't going to
be as effective as compared to the woman
who has an HRT of like 55 or 60. or a
vitamin D of 55 or 60 that HRT will work
better
interesting and vitman D comes from
sunlight
doesn't it sunlight and uh sardines
sardines it's the food sources are
really bad this is why everybody's low
in it
the food sources are it's sardines it's
like really fatty fishes and sunlight
and we spend most of our time indoors
that's right we can't get it from this
kind of light no no and you have to be
outside with your like skin exposed at
the high point of the day of the sun
like 12 1 o'clock
to get the most vitamin D and if you're
in a city where there's more air
pollution study has shown that you're
not going to the Rays that come in that
turn that will hit your skin and turn it
into Vitamin D are less because of air
pollution blocks it which is why so many
people are low in vitamin D which is why
taking vitamin D is a smart thing is
that why people are doing these like
infrared saunas and stuff now does that
produce vitamin D or is that something
else that's more detox it's pushing
infrared sauna it what it does is it uh
simulates a fever
so it burns things out from the inside
of the cell out which is why it's a
really good detoxer there was a few
things you said when I was watching some
of your YouTube videos that I wrote down
that I found really compelling one of
them was you said about the importance
of opening up our our detox Pathways and
you've just mentioned detoxing there
what do you mean by opening up our detox
Pathways yeah so if you look at our
lymph system each the lymph is is like
you know people know lymph nodes because
when you get sick you can feel them mums
yeah yeah so the lymph is always
carrying toxins out of organs
so liver the liver has a lymph pathway
the gut has lymph nodes in there that
are going to pull all the toxins that
are in there and move them out of you
so we need to keep these lymph Pathways
open so the gut the gut's a great one
you should be having a bowel movement
every single day if you're not having a
bowel movement every single day then the
what's what the body's trying to get rid
of is staying inside of you and it gets
congested
um a thing we teach women about the
armpit and actually would work for men
too is that you're you should have a pit
not a puff
if it's a puff like look in the mirror
and if your armpit is a puff then that
stagnant lymph it means that you're not
pulling the the toxins for women that
are coming out of her breasts or not
getting out toxins that are coming out
from the head down into the uh into the
thoracic areas not getting out because
it's congested so if your underarm is
Puffy and not
like a pit yeah then you might be
storing some of those toxins that's
right and they're not moving they're not
mobilizing why aren't they
am I blocking my Pathways yeah the
pathway is blocked so with what well
there's the question yeah with I feel
like people are going to leave this
podcast to be so depressed because
there's so many pieces of this but uh
deodorant deodorant clogs that up
and so it doesn't mobilize all of the
toxins out this was a big thing with
breast cancer there's a lot of women
using toxic deodorants they weren't
getting the toxins out of the breast and
it was clogging in the armpit because
the toxins from the deodorant
that explains why we sweat in that area
around ah because it's a pathway why do
we even have hair in that area I don't
know you tell me it's a detox it's for
detoxing it's to help get those toxins
out also the molecules go down the hair
yeah yeah and what do women do
shave it off that's right so you're
saying I
I I shave I I'm I just because I don't I
can't walk it's just not in my in my
nature but I you know what I do is I
have a loofah in my shower and I just
loofah under my arms whenever I shower
to open up those Pathways it's like a
little organic sponge I can't scrubs it
yeah scrubs it we also have pubic hair
we also have pubic hair we are getting
toxins out from the ovaries the ovaries
are the major area for and testes this
is where hormones are being produced
and so as they're coming out they are
supposed to influence our everything
biologically we need them to influence
but then they're also supposed to get
out of our system
and so the hair ends up becoming like
this way that we can mobilize the toxins
out of us I never what I never knew or
asked why I grow hair under my arms and
in the pubic region no one ever told me
about that no one ever I never
questioned it I thought it was slightly
inconvenient yes well it is for sure but
the body doesn't do anything to
inconvenience it does it to increase
your chances of survival because I'm the
byproduct of
millions of years of
survival of the fittest and evolution
that has made me
pruned a sculpted to survive it's funny
because we spend so much of our time and
this goes back to the conversation
around sugar we spend and just weight
loss and all these things we live in a
world where we think that our body is
against us right
right it's fighting us it's it's making
me go for the sugar drawer it's stopping
me losing weight
it's growing all these pubes right
inconvenient yeah yeah yeah and we fight
it so we shave it off and we you know do
all these crazy things to fight against
our body but our body is very much it's
it's actually
it's actually for us and many of the
things we're choosing to do are against
us we are against ourselves not our
bodies or bodies
cannot put a foot wrong
you got it I mean you got it it's this
is what I'm trying to bring back is this
this respect
for what the body's trying to do that's
what we're missing we we it's all
inconvenient and it's everything from
like even like weight gain like why is
your body gaining weight because it's so
brilliant that it decided not to put
that fat around your organs and put it
around your belly and now you're looking
in the mirror and you're villainizing it
but your body was trying to save your
life in that moment
like everything the body is always doing
for you not against you
but we continually
discredit what it's trying to do and
manipulate it which is why the best
thing I can think of is that we're just
in an evolutionary mismatch
we're just at the modern world does not
line up with the human body's design
quick one as you guys know we're lucky
enough to have blue jeans by Verizon as
a sponsor of this podcast and for anyone
that doesn't know blue jeans is an
online video conferencing tool that
allows you to have slick fast high
quality online meetings without all the
glitches you might normally find with
online meeting tools and they have a new
feature called Blue Jeans basic blue
jeans basic is essentially a free
version of their top quality video
conferencing tool that means you get an
immersive video experience that is super
high quality super easy and super
basically zero fast apart from all the
incredible features like zero time
limits on meeting calls it also comes
with High Fidelity audio and video
including Dolby voice which is
incredibly useful they also have
Enterprise grade security so you can
collaborate with confidence it's so
smooth that it's quite literally
changing the game for myself and my team
without compromising on quality to find
out more all you have to do is search
bluejeans.com and let me know how you
get on my girlfriend came upstairs
yesterday when I was having a shower and
she said to me that she tried the heel
protein shake which lives on my fridge
over there and she said it's amazing low
calories you get your 20 odd grams of
protein you get your 26 vitamins and
minerals and it's nutritionally complete
in the protein space there's lots of
things but it's hard to find something
that is nice especially when consumed
just with water and that is
nutritionally complete and that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein if
you haven't tried the heel protein
product do give it a try The Salted
Caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where he all fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one
something really pissed me off this
weekend I was walking through New York
City and I saw a poster and it is for
inject weight loss injections yeah have
you seen this no but ozampek is an is a
drug that's really popular right now
there's a couple of drugs right now
there's there's one my friends were
talking about it we were like there's a
diabetes drug I think and the headlines
have been that so many people are taking
this yeah diabetes drug to lose weight
that people with diabetes are struggling
um
there's another one called SEMA glutide
yep yep
this is this is people
injecting things in their body to help
them lose weight yeah and the poster
which my friend had sent me and I'd I'd
seen it earlier and then he'd sent me
the poster as well in our group chat
says one shot a week lose weight and it
has a little URL someone thankfully had
actually ripped the URL off this
billboard
um what's your take on all this stuff
yeah the the new medications that are
out there right now are creating a
weight loss uh possibility when we look
at the scale and when we look at how
people feel when they put on their
clothes but it's at the expense of
muscle they're actually losing more
muscle than they are losing fat
so yes you feel thinner but it's not
because you lost fat you lost muscle
is the organ of Longevity if you lose
muscle as you age you are going to be in
a bad situation I mean we need muscle to
get out of a chair yeah you need muscle
to perform daily life functions the
other thing people don't realize about
muscle is in muscle or insulin reset
receptors
so if you lose muscle you don't have as
many insulin receptors
which means you're now putting yourself
in a more insulin resistant state which
means you have to stay on the medication
forever to be able to stay at the weight
you want because you don't have the same
insulin sensitivity so again we're it's
like the calorie in calorie out
short-term result long-term consequence
it's not it's risky it's risky and then
you know every medication has a side
effect but I'm more concerned about the
person who thinks they solved their
weight loss issue and all they've done
is made it worse down the road
I sat here with many a health expert and
a fitness expert and nutritional expert
and they all agree with what you just
said about muscle they all said to me
because I asked a question too I think
it was Tim Spector about might have been
gels yo asked a question about do does
our metabolism fall off a cliff as we
age which is quite a popular thing and a
few of them said the same thing to me
they go at a certain point further down
the line metabolism does change but
really the thing that changed is muscle
mass and that means that we stop moving
as much which means that we gain weight
faster so he said the number one thing
that you need to do as you age is keep
doing resistance training keep your
muscle yep and because I was asking him
a question about my father I said I went
down this really steep cliff in Bali a
couple of weekends before and as I was
going down those stairs I was thinking
my dad couldn't do this anymore and at
the bottom of those stairs was our
activity for the day we were going white
water rafting and as I was walking down
those stairs I was thinking I want to be
my dad's age and be able to go down
these stairs so I can do stuff with my
kids
um and getting into a place where I'm
about at you know in my what 560. that
is a choice
that is an unavoid that is a for most of
us that is a choice and it's the one
that we can avoid if we keep muscle and
we keep therefore we'll keep fat and
what you've said there from what I
garnered from it is I will actually if I
take those
chemicals and if I inject them into my
body I'll lose my muscle mass and if I
lose my muscle mass
I will be
I will have a higher chance of weight
gain and obesity when I'm older
and and your functionality yeah so the
greatest the perfect example that I
always stuck in my head is my dad had a
knee surgery and he's 86 years old and I
remember trying to help him get around a
chair that he was sitting in and he was
starting to lose his upper body strength
and he literally couldn't push himself
up and out of the chair to be able to
move into a comfortable position and I
thought oh my gosh that's where muscle
is so important at 86 years old is just
being able to get up and out of a chair
after after recovering from a surgery
but if you think about the functionality
of a human as we age if you want to be
able to not do as many activities like
you're talking about just make sure you
don't have as much muscle like the
minute muscle goes away your
functionality goes away but more
importantly the minute muscle goes away
you're more insulin resistant so you're
going to gain weight more Down The Long
Haul
a lot of other people would say you know
the way to lose weight is just to do
lots of cardio
run a lot yeah good idea no no so here's
another interesting thing and I'm going
to give it through a woman's perspective
because we're good let's go back to
women over 40. so cortisol goes up with
extra cardio uh calorie set point
because you know you're more calorie
output so remember that's also happening
and you're changing your set point so I
need more calories
my calorie set point goes up and my
cortisol levels go up yep okay okay so
what ends up happening is that you
actually now are tanking all your other
hormones so let's follow the trail of
progesterone cortisol goes up because
you're you're doing so much cardio
so progesterone goes down
because cortisol goes up progesterone
goes down well progesterone keeps
estrogen in check
so now estrogen can go up and if you
have too much estrogen eventually what's
going to happen is it's going to be
stored as fat
so that extra hormone will so long term
that's not a great plan for women for
women for men uh well so then the second
piece applies to both men and women is
if you're doing a lot of cardio most
likely you're breaking down muscle to be
able to perform that cardio and a great
example is look at a marathon runner
versus a tennis player you know or a
soccer player like even though soccer
players are doing a lot of cardio it's a
lot of start stop start stop but a
marathon one Runner who's done so much
cardio is breaking muscle down to be
able to do that amount of cardio
so it's okay to do just not at the
expense of muscle and for women you
can't do it at the expense of
progesterone
so
it won't help me to lose weight
no you know what's going to help you to
lose weight is more weight lifting build
more muscle so you have more insulin
receptor sites fast more so you can get
rid of all of the glucose that gets
stored in muscles break your fast with
protein
and yeah I mean that's what we saw we
see all the time in both my clinic and
my online world is those three things
will get you in the shape that you want
it might not remember as you build
muscle you're not going to lose the the
number on the scale might be that much
different you know it might it might not
move but your whole shape is Gonna
Change you're gonna look different
so is any level of cardio good for
weight loss
would you recommend that just for the
broader health benefits you know I think
cardio is more of a mental health
Improvement improve you know you get all
those endorphins it's so good for your
mental health I love to go running it's
my favorite thing but I do it for my
mental health not to lose weight
another thing that I saw online which
was very curious that you said is you
were talking about how to undo the
oxidative damage from eating too much
sugar yeah what do you mean by that so
think about think about the cell as an
ecosystem right and so inside the cell
there has to be a balance of all the
right components so when glucose goes up
which happens when you eat too much
sugar that balance goes off and one of
the byproducts of that is that your body
puts off these free radicals it creates
more oxidative damage within the cell
the more of that oxidative damage the
more it's going to destroy mitochondria
and then and the nucleus and all the
Cellular Parts
so what you're doing when you're fasting
is you're reestablishing balance into
the cell and you're allowing to your
body to naturally undo the oxidative
damage that happened from poor living so
it's like a reset on it's like a
cellular reset
people say that there's been a school of
thought that fasting breaks down muscle
that I'll lose muscle if I fast true or
false so it appears to break down muscle
you it depends on how long you're in a
fast but it will appear as if your
muscle is shrinking because it's getting
rid of the stored sugar
but when you now bring in a high protein
meal and feed it amino acids it will
grow stronger you'll see more definition
because it broke the sugar down which
you don't want in there
so it changes the the shape of the
muscle
makes it more lean I guess it makes it
more lean but if you follow that up with
good eating you're going to make
yourself stronger now the person who
decides to go into a fast breaks down
muscle
and doesn't follow up with good eating
yeah you're going to end up with less
muscle
but if you follow it up with a lot of
protein and you build that mtor back up
now you're actually able to build your
muscle even stronger there's two ways to
build muscle one is through weights
lifting weight strength training and the
other is through food protein
so all fasting is doing is leaning it
out and does fasting have an impact on
my sleep
a couple of ways
um sleep for starters if your brain's
inflamed you're not going to sleep so
fasting brings down inflammation so that
would be the first thing the other thing
is that a lot of people wake up
especially women two three in the
morning and they kind of get the jolt
out of bed and a lot of times that's
because you've maybe had dinner at seven
o'clock glucose is going down and so the
body registers that glucose has gone
down and so it gives you a cortisol
Spike and all of a sudden you wake up at
two or three in the morning is that why
some people wake up at I've got a friend
of mine that's um an elderly male and he
always tells me because I wake up at 3am
last night and he's constantly saying it
he's like I woke up in the middle of the
night again last night yep and I've
always wondered why and we when I'm with
him we do eat dinner particularly late
yeah
yeah so he's probably getting so he has
all that glucose he goes to sleep and
now the glucose starts to go down and
then there's going to be a point at
which the body registers that it hits a
new low and then it triggers it and and
all of a sudden triggers cortisol and
releases glucose from other body parts
okay and the body takes that as we're
running from a tiger get up out of bed
yeah and to avoid that what would use
your use not eating so late yeah not
eating so late but the more you fast the
more you're you stabilize that blood
sugar and you don't have those highs and
lows as much it's it's a com it's a way
of bringing balance back to the whole
blood sugar system
I have to say you know we talk a lot
about I mean we've talked extensively
about fasting today and one of the
concerns I have about talking about the
subject matter is the implications it
has for people with eating disorders
um because it's quite easy to conflate
messages if if if
you're not able to fully understand the
context of everything yeah and I'm sure
that's a topic you've you've thought
about I mean I think you've actually
read about it in one of the latest
chapters in your book in chapter 10 yeah
um
it's a it's it's a common it's it's one
that we thought a lot about when we
wrote the book so I I want to say that
first that
um when the book was put together that
was definitely something my agent the
publisher everybody was really keen on
how can we tread that lightly and here's
my stance on it the first is that if you
have a severe eating disorder I'm going
to recommend that if you want to learn
to fast you need to bring your therapist
into it you need to bring your doctor
into it you need another set of eyes to
help you navigate that
so that would be the first thing that I
would say second thing I'm going to go
back to this woman that I worked with
who had severe eating disorders and and
she's been very very public about her
eating disorders and I didn't start with
fasting I started with food with her
so we started by stabilizing her blood
sugar first and then once I saw that
those spikes on her glucose monitor were
were in a place I wanted were more
steady then I introduced fasting because
she was seeing food as a real healing
tool and then I could put patch on
fasting as an adjunct to it and she's
doing incredible incredible so you it's
there's just a different approach but I
really encourage that you work with your
practitioner or your therapist
where do I start I'm sold you sold me on
fasting I'm going to become a faster
where do I start Mindy so the first
place to start is you want to think
about compressing your food into one
eating window so let me start by asking
you what time do you typically finish
eating dinner
I told you this I've covered I told you
not to mention it
on a good day
on an Ideal day so my my issue is
um I'm gonna be honest because that's
the point of this podcast
um the issue I have is I wake up in the
morning
I then Begin work and I'll get I'll eat
my first meal this is quite shocking in
fact I'll eat my first meal around
I'm gonna say between 2 p.m and
4 P.M depending on how busy my schedule
is sometimes there's been days I
remember one particular day it's
actually when I found out that I do this
I took someone with me for the day they
were shadowing me for the day and I got
to 7pm and they go we haven't eaten
today oh wow and I didn't notice I had
no idea that I hadn't eaten that day so
I'm a very late eater but then the issue
is I will go to the gym usually in the
evening usually after work often between
9 p.m and 11 p.m and then when I get
home from the gym oh no
I go to sleep like a good boy no I this
is where you go around yeah this is
where it goes downhill then I'll eat
then I'll eat something
um
pretty late at night
and that could be midnight
so you're so what I heard in that is
your eating window is two to twelve
twelve yeah so that you're you're in a
10 hour eating window yeah so in in if
you in the morning are you doing coffee
yeah yeah I do now mainly because of
this podcast but okay yeah but you're
not eating anything else in the morning
no not really no no I don't eat
breakfast there's no days in my life
where I eat breakfast really
um the earliest I might eat is midday
okay
so if you choose to make two your time
that you I call it opening up your
eating window you're going to start
eating so you would go 2 to 12 that's 10
hour eating window it's not and we'll
work on your window here in a moment
that that's leaving 14 hours of fasting
um about 15 hours you're gonna start to
get the testosterone increase so I would
say let's can we make it a nine or an
even an eight hour eating window
especially because you told me your
goals and and your fitness goals I would
think for you an eight-hour eating
window would be great so you have an
option you can either not eat when you
get home from the gym and now we're at
oh I'm just so hungry right or you could
push it back to three before or four you
said sometimes where you don't where you
don't eat what would be ideal
um well for you definitely just don't
want to eat when it's dark out so ideal
would be an eight hour eating window
finishing right now it's summer so
finishing at nine
and then you would work back yeah so you
would do like one to nine
or twelve to eight or twelve to eight
yeah or 11 till 7. right it's not gonna
happen I'll do I'll do the uh the one
till nine yeah that you said yeah
because I go to the gym often quite late
in the UK so I mean definitely after the
gym and then here's here's a little hack
is that and and I want to make sure that
people don't lose sight what I just did
with you is customize it to your
lifestyle and I think that's really
important you just take that eating
window and you figure out what's the
best where it fits for you
um I I do this with people who have
families they want to sit down and eat
dinner so don't skip dinner with your
kids like sit and enjoy that you sound
like that that from a fitness and work
level that's working for you so let's
let's let's keep it like that let's not
move that around too much but for your
fitness goals one day a week I'd like to
see you elongate your fast push your
fast like could you go 20 hours 24 hours
of fasting where you're just having one
meal a day because what you're going to
do is you're going to put your body into
a little bit of a state of stress where
it all the things we've talked about are
going to start to the healing is going
to happen at a much quicker rate you're
saying once in a while yes once a week
for you once a week yeah so once a week
go like 24 hours yeah eating that's
right or what you call it one meal a day
wow okay
anything else I need to know to get
started
um I mean coffee can be your friend
um uh putting MCT oil in it can help you
get ketones a little bit quicker so I
don't know if you ever put oil in your
coffee but I have mct2 oil on my counter
at home because I did keep the keto diet
yeah so just put it in your coffee it'll
switch you over and it'll get those
ketones going a little quicker there is
something I wrote about in the book
called a fasted snack and the fasted
snack is pure Fat Mom they're hard to
find I'll tell you it's a fat bomb so
it's it has no carbs very little protein
it's all fat so an example of one might
be an avocado is pretty fat dense it has
it does have some carbs but the one I
love it's something called a keto cup
and it's MCT oil with cacao butter and
some chocolate just pure chocolate
around wrapped around it it looks like a
little Reese's Peanut Butter Cups and I
you can do those in your fasting window
and they'll keep they they won't switch
you over because they're pure fat
so fasted snacks or it can be really
helpful the research shows that you get
all the benefits of fasting but you're
popping these little keto cups in your
mouth all day long what is the most
important thing we haven't talked about
in your view oh
I you know I think the most important
thing is for people to realize that
there's not the perfect path there's
just your path
so take all everything we talked about
and find the threads that resonate with
you and put those into action and then
maybe you come back and listen to the
podcast again and you take another
thread but we have to stop trying to do
our diet like everybody else around us
there's your diet and that's really what
I'm trying to get is that people build a
lifestyle that's unique to them and a
one will it be your own n of one
it's really the most beautiful place to
live
and of one
yeah you know they'd say in a in a study
they always say like the N is how many
people are in the study and so they'll
say like n of a hundred n of a thousand
so n of one is one person was in the
study be your own study you don't be
your own study you're an experiment yeah
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest and the
question that's been left in the Diary
of a CEO for you is
interesting
oh
it's it's actually not that profound or
interesting but but it's
I feel like
you're the type of person that will
interpret a deeper meaning than this
question maybe is alluding to but
really think about this okay
how do you
take care
of you
that's actually that's a great question
um
I could answer that question on a health
level like I I have a really strong
Health routine I get up in the morning I
meditate I have a hyperbaric oxygen
chamber at home I pop in my chamber I
read like I at the first two hours of my
day are for me first before anybody else
so I have that part of me but I want to
give a a deeper answer to that
um
I'm really getting to know myself and
what my needs are especially as a 53
year old woman who's moving through
menopause and really honoring that
how I care for myself is more important
than anything else and what I mean by
that is when I say no to things not over
scheduling myself putting my needs
before everybody else's these are things
I haven't done in my life and right now
I'm really working on caring for myself
first so that I can pour love into the
world after that love me first
why is that important
think for me I have been in the healing
profession for so long I've been a
mother a wife and I've done everything
for everybody else
and I stand here at 53 saying I'm going
to start doing things for me now
and that feels that feels like self-love
and that feels like where health is
going to live for me
and I haven't I haven't spent much time
doing that in my life so I'm learning to
do it for the first time now
Mindy Dr Mindy tells that is beautiful
thank you so much thank you so much for
your wisdom
um your remarkable engaging captivating
Storyteller author content creator and a
wonderful practitioner everything you do
you've helped so many people with your
work and I'm so excited when they told
me I'd be have the honor of having a
conversation with you today this is one
of those conversations that genuinely
will change people's lives and isn't
that an amazing thing it's really cool
yeah isn't that an amazing thing that we
can sit here and all the stuff you've
shared will have a significant impact on
one person's life millions of people's
lives hundreds of thousands of people's
lives which will mean that they live a
more fulfilled existence they can kiss
there and hug their kids for longer and
that is because of the work you do so on
behalf of all of those people who may
never get to meet you in person and
thank you themselves thank you oh thank
you I just really appreciate the
opportunity to be here for the
thoughtful questions and really allowing
me to express what I I hope hope does
exactly that and I think the purpose of
of living a fulfilled life is touching
humans you never actually meet
amen
some of you will know that this podcast
is now sponsored by the incredible
Airbnb I'm a huge user lover and
customer of Airbnb every time I go away
on a trip whether that's work related or
it's a holiday Airbnb is always my go-to
but have you ever considered have you
ever thought about making some extra
cash to cover some bills or to help pay
off a holiday let me explain further
perhaps people are coming to your town
or city for a music festival for an
event or a holiday and you have a spare
room why not Airbnb it or your home
office is free right now you're working
away from home during the week you can
Airbnb it honestly the possibilities are
endless I've Airbnb one of my Apartments
before and it's a great way to make
extra cash I'd highly recommend you all
to at least check it out that extra
space you have that extra room it might
be worth more than you think so to find
out just how much it's worth search
airbnb.co.uk host that's airbnb.co.uk
host
oh
[Music]
foreign